Hey youtubers it's Charlie and Stephen Amell
and the CW have been dropping Season 3 bombs
for the past week. Including 4 new characters
and some new developments with Harley Quinn
in relation to the Suicide Squad. So this
video is going to be a breakdown of all this
new stuff.
Hello to all the new people who are just finding
me for the first time. I'm do weekly DC and
Marvel bonus videos for stuff like Arrow,
Marvel Movies and Gotham. Be sure to subscribe
to get everything. Comic Con is coming up
and everyone is going to be dropping a bunch
of details for the new seasons this fall.
Speaking of which, let's start with the new
Arrow Characters. These are all based on character
sheets released by the network. The first
is Daniel, here's the character description
this is a little silly but you'll see:
a major recurring character for Season 3 — is
a handsome, enigmatic and highly intelligent
entrepreneur developing groundbreaking technology.
then in quotation marks it says (Picture a
business magnate in Ryan Gosling's body.)
Though exuding charm and confidence in public,
he privately harbors a tragic past that will
drive him to become a tech-powered superhero.
Watch for this formidable fella to be a love
interest for Felicity and a rival of Oliver's
-- both personally and professionally.
This is a huge deal, it sounds like he's going
to be Daniel Garrett, the Golden Age Blue
Beetle. He first appeared in the comics in
1939 in Mystery Men. He wasn't like the Ted
Kord Blue Beetle. He was a police officer
that took a serum to make him super strong
and wore a bulletproof costume when fighting
crime.
So that doesn't sound exactly like the character
description the network released. It's possible
that they're using the classic name with the
new character, or that Daniel name is just
a red herring to throw people off and they're
really casting Ted Kord.
Kord Industries is the one that made the mega
centrifuge that Slade stole to mass produce
the Mirakuru and Queen Industries research
department has probably been doing business
with them for a long time.
Ted Kord would be one of the few ways Oliver
could get his company back too. If you guys
aren't familiar with the character, or you
didn't see him on Smallville. He's like a
Hank Pym type character. Not quite up to the
level of Tony Stark or Bruce Wayne in terms
of wealth or popularity, but he still has
a massive company and he's one of the super
Ted Kord in the comics though is something
of an underdog, like a silly tech genius who
uses his devices to fight crime. His version
of the Blue Beetle was never able to unlock
the powers of the scarab. Something that the
Jaime Reyes character did after he took up
the mantle.
Looking at the origin of the Ted Kord Blue
Beetle might offer some clues for the villain
this season too.
Ted Kord became Blue Beetle after Daniel Garrett
died in battle. They were investigating Ted
Kord's uncle Jarvis Kord. He was trying to
build an army of androids to take over the
world.
Arrow has a history of changing the comic
book versions of characters like with Black
Canary and Sara, so don't be surprised if
they swap some details. But the Scarab will
be a big deal and Kord Industries.
The cool thing about them developing the Blue
Beetle Character and having Amanda Waller
around is that now they have a backdoor to
Maxwell Lord and Checkmate. Smallville did
Checkmate already, so Arrow might wait before
doing their version of it. But it's another
big organization that will definitely make
an appearance in a future season.
The funny thing about this is that I can already
see the tumblr 'ships sailing on Daniel and
Felicity. I have a feeling that The Flash
tv show is going to be pushing the Barry Iris
relationship so it makes sense that Arrow
will start pushing for Daniel and Felicity.
He sounds like he's going to be helping Oliver,
but that he'll be a big enough personality
that he can challenge Oliver's badassery.
The other possibilities are that Daniel is
Mister Terrific or Daniel Cassidy aka The
Blue Devil as foreshadowed on the bus in season
2. But none of those characters fit the description
as well as Blue Beetle. So I'm going to stick
with that.
Remember, Isabel Rochev was Ravager without
being Rose Wilson. Arrow has been known to
change things.
The Second new character is named Seth, here's
his character description from the network:
A well-educated criminal with grand ambitions
and a knack for chemistry, this potentially
recurring character gains power over his enemies
by exposing them to a drug that drains their
willpower. Oh, and he is very much a physical
match for The Arrow.
The closest people this sounds like are Scarecrow
or Parasite. But because the Jonathan Crane
character isn't even close to being a physical
match for Oliver and Parasite doesn't use
chemistry we'll have to wait for some better
details to figure out who he is.
Based on the description it sounds like he'll
occupy the villain position that Brother Blood
occupied. Like the villain we see first, then
later a bigger villain will emerge from the
shadows.
The next two characters are both Hong Kong
Flashback people named Toshi and his wife
Here's the character descriptions: Toshi will
serve as Oliver's teacher and handler, and
eventually become a friend. A well-trained
operative, skilled in weaponry, combat and
intelligence gathering, he is also a devoted
father and husband.
Akiko is his wife and another of Oliver's
Hong Kong caretakers, and is herself highly
skilled in martial arts.
Toshi sounds like he's going to be an original
character like Diggle. Or the prequel to Diggle
and the inspiration for Oliver wanting to
build a team in present day. A lot of superheroes
like Batman tend to work alone, Oliver chooses
to work with a team for a reason, so the Hong
Kong flashbacks this season will probably
explain why that is.
Akiko is a little more exciting because she
could totally be Lady Shiva which everyone
has been asking for this year or she could
be Katana.
The Katana character just got a new comic
book series that launched around the same
time the new Vibe comic launched. And that
character is a regular on the new Flash tv
show. Katana also appears in the New 52 version
of the Birds of Prey comic. Blue Beetle has
also appeared in Birds of Prey.
We know Arrow will be doing more Birds of
Prey stories in season 3, so I'm actually
going to say Katana is a better guess for
Akiko's character.
And just because those two characters are
flashback characters doesn't mean we won't
see them in present day. I've got my fingers
crossed for a present day Hong Kong or China
trip.
Here's a quick update on Harley Quinn from
Stephen Amell. He was at Phoenix Comic Con
recently and said that he's really hoping
to see Harley Quinn out of her cell next season,
so it sounds like the show is going to try
and use her if everything behind the scenes
works out.
Part of the issue with them using comic book
characters is that they have to get clearance
from Warner Brothers. They can't just cast
Batman or Nightwing without getting approval.
Even though Warner Brothers owns both Arrow
the show, the characters and the Network it
airs on.
It's a bit of a mess, but since Stephen Amell
keeps bugging them to use her again, the odds
of us seeing her went up exponentially. Cassidy
Alexa played her on screen and Tara Strong
did the voice.
Stephen Amell said this funny thing that when
it comes to tv, if it looks good, it has a
much better chance of happening. And I think
everyone agreed that Cassidy Alexa's version
of Harley was pretty awesome. I'm expecting
to hear more about this at Comic Con this
year.
Arrow Season 3 actually starts filming 3 weeks
from today. So once they start filming outside
we might get a look at some of the new characters.
I'll be doing bonus videos every week so feel
free to leave me suggestions about Arrowverse
things you guys want to talk about.
Jason Momoa is supposedly going to be Aquaman
in the Batman vs Superman movie, it's not
confirmed so I wasn't planning on doing a
video. But There was a bunch of details leaked
about the plot of Avengers 2, so I'll probably
be doing a spoilery video for that next. I'll
be sure to add spoiler warnings. Be sure to
subscribe to get it. I should be able to post
it later tonight.
Right now click here to learn more about Arrow
Season 3 and click here to learn more about
Avengers 2.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!